a 16 year old girl is speaking out after
she says that she was sexually assaulted
on a United Airlines flight the teenager
was flying from Seattle to Newark back
in July and she and her mother have
asked us to protect their identities and
we've done that and a Warner talked to
them in an interview you will see only
on CBS this morning Anna's at the
seattle-tacoma Airport and a good
morning well good morning this was a big
trip for that high schooler she had one
admission to a prestigious Young Women's
Leadership Academy at Princeton
University but she says her red-eye
flight on United Airlines soon took a
traumatic turn I knew what was going on
but like I just thought I was dreaming
or something like this cannot really be
happening the 16 year old girl was
traveling alone from Seattle sleeping on
her overnight united flight to Newark
when she says she awoke to find the
stranger sitting next to her touching
her they could feel his hand on my thigh
and one of his hands had I came between
my legs and he was like rubbing me
between my legs and then he tried to put
his other hand like underneath my pants
and then I kind of woke up and I was
like what are you doing she reported it
to a flight attendant who moved her to
another seat a few rows up but says she
was terrified they just felt like he
could see me like he could see wherever
I was sitting and why did that terrify
you because there was just still so much
time like I couldn't just leave the
plane I didn't have anyone I didn't feel
like there was anyone on the plane that
could protect me and when the plane
parked at the gate in Newark the
teenager says everyone simply walked off
including the man she says sexually
assaulted her I literally thought I was
gonna die this is the 16 year olds
mother you thought you were gonna die
I'm 3,000 miles away my child says she's
been sexually assaulted and I'm asking
her questions and she's like disoriented
I'm like oh where is he do you see him
and she said he just walked by me and I
said get the police get United but her
mother says when she finally got a
United Terminal supervisor on the phone
at that point the supervisor told me
that United did not follow their own
protocols she said you are the first
person telling me of your daughter's
assault I don't have
the manifest I don't have a report I
don't even know who he is or where he is
later that day police and the FBI which
handles incidents in the air did track
down a passenger and arrest him Vijay
Kumar Krishna a visiting doctor on a
fellowship according to one Medical
Centre is charged with one count of
abusive sexual contact on an airplane
his attorney says Krishna adamantly
denies the charges and deserves to be
considered an innocent man United did
not answer CBS's questions including
about its protocol for reporting sexual
assaults instead saying in a statement
we take these allegations seriously and
are working with the authorities but
family attorney mark Lambert faults
United the FBI wasn't waiting when the
plane landed so the perpetrator the the
the man who engaged in sexual assault
walked off the plane with a free pass
the FBI reports in 2016 it conducted 57
investigations into sexual assaults on
airplanes up from 40 in 2015 it's a
statistic this mother never knew if I
had any inclination that she could be
assaulted I never would have put my
daughter on that flight I would have
flown with her he said that he took
something from you
what did he take from you do you think
he had no right to touch me he had no
right I guess I would say he took my
peace of mind you don't feel safe no I
don't feel safe and Krishna is currently
out on bail if convicted he could face
two years in prison a $250,000 fine and
possibly be deported the FAA says that
airlines regularly do summon law
enforcement to meet a plane in the
incident of an alleged crime such as
this one but it certainly appears in
this case Norah that that may not have
happened
thank you Anna you certainly feel the
daughter's pain and the mother's pain
and you does make you wonder somebody
dropped the ball there why wasn't there
an authority figure there too
yeah stop this man who talked to him we
wait disturbing hope they get this right
yeah and in the sense of what it means
to people who feel like they've been
invaded that's right this whole
investigation continues